bonjour nouveau débat sur tv 78 dans le
cadre du premier tour des élections
municipales aujourd'hui consacré attrape
un débat également diffusée sur radio
sensations 98.4 dans les yvelines
trois représentants des listes déclarées
au 17 février date de cette émission qui
ont accepté de venir aujourd'hui en
plateau ottomane nasri aujourd'hui
conseiller municipal d'opposition et
tête de liste engagement trappe citoyens
ali rabais adjoint au maire membre de la
majorité sortante tête de liste pour que
tu rappes respirer guy malandain maire
sortant tête de liste la gauche qui agit
bonsoir à tous les trois et merci
d'avoir accepté cette invitation je
précise qu une quatrième liste citoyen
en actions annonce également être en
train de se préparer pour ce scrutin
nous les avons sollicités son succès
pour participer à cette émission le
temps de parole je vous le rappelle sera
chronométrée afin de garantir au mieux l
égalité et nous débutons ce premier
retour de ce premier tour de table comme
à chaque fois avec cette question
pourquoi vous présentez pourquoi les
électeurs devraient vous faire confiance
nous avons procédé à un tirage au sort
avant cette émission
et c'est avec vous autres magnats stroke
nous allons débuter vous siégez donc
dans l'opposition je me disais vous êtes
vous étiez candidat en 2014
aujourd'hui allié à mustapha larbaoui
ancien président du club de football
local engagé sur la commune et qui
souhaitaient pendant un temps se
présenter seul en tant que tête de liste
vous êtes aussi à la tête du groupe
majoritaire de la droite à la région ile
de france
donc cette question pourquoi vous
présentez pour 2020 attrape alors tout
d'abord un grand merci pour votre
invitation parce qu'il est important que
le débat se fasse sur le fond et en 2014
puisque c'est effectivement ce que vous
disiez les trappistes m'ont fait
l'honneur de me mettre à la seconde
place des élections municipales avec un
score de plus de 30%
le ca fait donc six années que je suis
élu de la ville que je j anime
l'opposition municipale et je crois
pouvoir dire qu'aujourd'hui je connais
parfaitement bien tous les dossiers de
la ville
depuis j'ai pris des responsabilités je
suis vice-président de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines en charge
du développement économique et puis vous
l'avais dit à l'instant je suis élu de
la région ile de france j'ai été d'abord
vice président de la région et désormais
je préside la majorité régionale
ça veut dire que j'ai la capacité d'être
utile attrapez trappistes j'ai gagné en
expérience et j'ai la capacité de
financer des projets concrets sur trappe
je les ai déjà fait ces dernières années
sur un certain nombre de dossiers
avec l'idée finalement assez simple
c'est que pendant les vingt années de
mandat de guy malandain des choses
utiles ont été réalisés mais je
considère qu'il reste beaucoup à faire
sur un certain nombre de sujets je pense
à la réussite scolaire à l'emploi à la
sécurité au cadre de vie aux impôts
locaux
sur tous ces sujets je considère que le
compte n'y est pas et qu'on peut faire
beaucoup mieux que les trappistes ont le
droit d'attendre plus de résultats de la
part de leurs élus c'est donc maintenant
que je peux être utile
j'ai fait le choix de rester fidèle à
trappes comme je m'y étais engagé en
2014 et nous l'avons nous avons
construit vous l'avez dit avec mustapha
larbaoui un vrai rassemblement local
parce que gérer une ville c'est bien sûr
se rassembler tous les habitants et le
débat on va vouloir nous imposer un
débat d'étiquette politique mais un
mandat municipal n'est pas un mandat
partisans ma sensibilité politique
elle est connue elle est assumée mais
encore une fois pourtant gèrent des
écoles quand on veut attirer des
médecins quand on veut diversifier les
commerces et bien on cherche surtout de
la compétence du sérieux drake
crédibilité et c'est pour cela
qu'aujourd'hui je suis à nouveau
candidat à les rabais vous êtes adjoint
au maire sortant vous avez décidé
néanmoins de prendre un peu vos
distances puisque vous êtes têtes de
listes pour ce scrutin vous êtes
investis par génération notamment pour
conduire une liste de rassemblement à
gauche avec le soutien du pcf même
question vous avez deux minutes même
temps à imposer pour vous pour nous
expliquer vos motivations pour cette
élection 2020 merci de votre habitation
compléter votre présentation je suis
soutenue par le parti communiste
français attrape mais également par
europe ecologie les verts dont un
rassemblement de la gauche est déjà en
marche à l'oeuvre pour permettre de
porter la candidature et la liste que
j'ai constitué et si je suis candidat
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord parce que
j'estime qu'il faut de la clarté dans le
paysage politique à trappes et qu'il
faut être capable de parler en toute
transparence aux électeurs des
différentes offres qui seront face à
face à eux lors de l'élection du 15 et
du 22 mars
trois listes essentiellement vont se
présentent aux suffrages des trappistes
une liste portée par othman nasri qui
l'assumé je l'en remercie
quel candidat de la droite sur trappe et
qui portera donc l'étiquette et les
couleurs de la droite qu'en nommant
comme en 2014 guy malandain le maire
sortant a décidé de se présenter pour la
cinquième fois et j'ai été en désaccord
avec guy malandain sucrant certain
nombre de points tout au long de son
mandat mais surtout sur la perspective
d'une cinquième candidature
or compte 2014 lorsque nous avons été
présents ensemble sur la même liste
guy malandain s'était engagé à ne pas
présenter de candidatures en 2020 par
ailleurs nous avons d'autres désaccords
qui justifie que je prenne mes
responsabilités la liste portée par guy
malandain aura le soutien d'un certain
nombre de formations politiques c'est
très bien dont celui de la république en
marche
le parti du président emmanuel macron
moi j'ai une vie à trappes comme
trappistes qui me permet tout au long de
l'année de côtoyer ceux qui souffrent
des politiques menées par le
gouvernement actuel et je ne peux pas
assumer d'être dans une équipe
municipale qui sera soutenu par la
république en marche c'est pourquoi j'ai
pris mes responsabilités j'ai choisi de
constituer une équipe avec les
formations politiques de gauche de
trappes
nous portons un projet de gauche et nous
mobilisons les énergies citoyennes parce
que sur ma liste
au delà des étiquettes partisanes nous
aurons de très nombreux présidents et
présidentes d'associations représentant
des parents d'élèves dans les conseils
d'école membres des comités de quartier
et forces vives trappistes s'organise
autour de ma candidature et nous allons
ensemble porter un projet précis
détaillé chiffré est financée j'y tiens
énormément parce que nous ne sommes pas
là pour multiplie les promesses et
promettre de raser gratis autres à pis
nous devrons être capables d'assumer
chaque proposition que nous porterons et
pour conclure la crédibilité de la
parole politique ce qui permet justement
de faire revenir les citoyens aux urnes
c'est de tenir les engagements comprend
non pas multiplier les promesses pas
multiplier les projets non financées
mais être capable de détailler ce que
l'on va faire je vous arrête là prenez
un tout petit peu plus d'avancé vous
êtes à 2 minutes 15 à peu près une
minute quarante huit pour votre manas
rocky malandain c'est à vous vous êtes
également candidat maire depuis 2001
vous présidiez donc un nouveau mandat
vous êtes soutenus par la république en
marge mais aussi par le parti socialiste
ou encore le prg pourquoi votre nouvelle
candidature en 2020 alors j'ai déjà
répondu de nombreuses fois à cette
question moi je suis arrivé à trappes en
1069 du travail et j'étais député
trabant 80 et conseiller municipal puis
puis mer à partir de 95
et c'est une ville dont on ne peut pas
se passer quand on y est ancrée quand on
y est tous les jours du matin jusqu'au
soir et que la moitié de son temps est
passé à dire bonjour dans la rue au
marché qui s'était resterait donc le
premier point de la poursuite de nos
mandats c'est un point humain ça peut
paraître déplacé à l'époque l'envi mais
moi j'y tiens beaucoup
les habitantes tra pour marc compte plus
que tout et j'ai bien envie s'ils le
souhaitent de consacrer encore beaucoup
de temps beaucoup de temps pour vous
pour eux le deuxième le deuxième est
éléments après on peut juger comme
veulent ce qui s'est fait à trappes
c'est que j'ai comment on peut dire
hérité j'ai pas si le mouchard viscom
hérité au en 2001 d'une ville qui avait
des difficultés très très importante
un déficit financier de 26 millions
d'euros que des choses de ce genre là
avec vraiment une situation et urbaine
et sociale extrêmement compliqué et nous
avons travaillé jeudi nous oui parce que
c'est pas tout seul j'ai conduit thoune
et tout ça à faire de la ville de
trappes lui dirait une ville comme les
autres sont toutes différentes mais qui
n'est pas avec des des espaces non non
urbanisées en plein coeur de la ville
etc
enfin faut se souvenir de tout ça au
point où on en est on prêt on en est
aujourd'hui nous nous avons accompli un
premier contrat de renouvellement urbain
ça plaît ou ça plaît pas mais ça se boit
nous allons lancer était jeudi à l
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
pour démarrer le
le dossier me contrat de renouvellement
urbain de valence est thématique
peut-être après mais vous interrompre
aussi vous ayez un peu de temps pour
répondre aux différentes questions sur
les différentes thématiques
il avait deux passions humaines est une
nécessité comment dire l'urban des
techniques si je puis synthétiser de
sept modèles
voilà pour ce premier tour de table
voici un sujet qui revient sur quelques
uns seulement des enjeux et a attrapé
puis nous développerons tout ça ensuite
en plateau le projet est dans toutes les
têtes depuis 20 ans longtemps au point
mort l'enfouissement de la nationale 10
à bien démarrer un chantier préparatoire
en 2019 le début aussi des travaux
d'aménagement cette année avec la
création d'un mur de protection et la
destruction du pont marcel cachin près
de la mairie prévue cet été
le projet comprend le dénivellement de
l' axe routier qui coupe la ville en
deux la création de trois plateaux
urbain et de deux ronds points en entrée
et sortie de ville coût total estimé
plus de 95 millions d'euros
comme dans d'autres communes c'est la
sécurité qui est au coeur des
préoccupations des habitants trappe
touché par la radicalisation avec des
dizaines de départs vers la syrie par le
trafic de stupéfiants et par les
règlements de comptes entre bandes la
mort du petit moussa en 2015 avait
grandement ému
la ville fait partie des quartiers de la
reconquête républicaine identifiés par
l'état depuis plusieurs mois la police
de sécurité du quotidien est déployée
avec deux unités de patrouilles à pied
au contact de la population trappe ou la
moitié des 33 mille habitants à moins de
30 ans 25% au moins de 15 ans la
jeunesse est donc également un enjeu un
projet éducatif de territoire a été
défini et c'est un collège dit innovant
qui pourrait voir le jour sur place dans
les prochaines années
thématique dans la continuité répondre à
la problématique d'emplois dans la ville
où le taux de chômage s'élève à 19 % 5
points au-dessus de la moyenne régionale
25% de la population trappistes
vivraient sous le seuil de pauvreté
enfin trap est une ville qui a
énormément changé profitant d'un vaste
plan de rénovation urbaine de 350
millions d'euros les habitants veulent
encore plus de mixité dans le logement
de nouveaux projets de construction
pourrait voir le jour prochainement
nous débutons poursuivons pardon ce
débat consacré à trappes sur tv 78 aussi
sur radio sensations et nous parlons
d'urbanisme pour débuter sur les
thématiques il ya certes des projets
d'aménagement de construction il ya des
dossiers de réaménagement aussi de
rénovation urbaine comme au square camus
par exemple et puis comment mettre de
côté à la nationale 10 et son
enfouissement
on pourrait vous faire réagir sur tous
ces sujets on va commencer avec vos
autres magnats through savez un tout
petit peu plus de retard après le
premier tour de table premier tour de
parole
d'une manière générale sur l'urbanisme
vous dites il faut arrêter de bétonner
la ville et changer un peu les règles
d'urbanisme
évidemment je crois que on a atteint
aujourd'hui le maximum de la
densification qu'il faut sur trappe et
je le dis en toute cohérence puisque
pendant six années j'ai répété cela au
conseil municipal je suis le seul élu
autour de cette table à avoir voté
contre tous les projets de construction
immobilière contre le plan local de
l'habitat c'était en février dernier en
février 2019 qui prévoit deux mille
trois cents nouveaux logements
supplémentaires et donc le maire sortant
comme son adjoint désormais candidat ans
tous les deux voté pour ces objectifs là
c'est de cela dont on doit parler
aujourd'hui parce que évidemment que
maintenant il faut faire des espaces
verts il faut s'occuper des commerces il
faut s'occuper du cadre de vie
les autres villes y arrive les autres
villes y arrive qu'on ne me dise pas que
ce n'est pas possible attrape les
trappistes ont tous qui le droit à un
cadre de vie de qualité et c'est
exactement le projet que l'on propose
donc ça veut dire revoir les règles
d'urbanisme pour protéger le tissu
pavillonnaire dans une fois je sais que
certains veulent faire de cette élection
une élection nationale avec un débat
entre la droite et la gauche mais ce
n'est pas moi qui ai vendu la vie le
promoteur immobilier
ce sont ces l'équipe municipale qui est
aujourd'hui aux responsabilités donc
soyons clair il faut dire stop à la
densification stop à la bétonisation ce
qui a été fait et est certainement utile
maintenant il faut s'arrêter
il faut faire des espaces verts un tissu
pavillonnaire plus important et puis
surtout surtout travaillé sur les
commerces sur les professions de santé
et sur le cadre de vie et là dessus on
quand une fois les trappistes peuvent
avoir beaucoup mieux que ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui à lire à bas vous dit aussi
qu'il faut sanctuariser certaines zones
pavillonnaires par exemple je pense
qu'il faudra qu'on retravaille le plan
local d'urbanisme faire en sorte que là
où on vit dans des pavillons
salut c'est mon cas j'habite le quartier
de la boissière attrape je suis le seul
des trois candidats qui vit à trappes
parmi les trappistes
je souhaite qu'on puisse faire en sorte
de
sanctuary faisait ces espaces et qu'on
ne se retrouve pas entre deux pavillons
avec un immeuble de quatre étages c'est
malheureusement le cas de certains
projets d'urbanisme en cours il faut y
mettre fin parce que notre ville avait
besoin de croître la population de
trappes a diminué puis de nouveau
augmenté mais il est temps maintenant de
stabiliser les effectifs de la ville de
trappes parce que construire pour
construire n'est pas un objectif en soi
nous avons besoin d' espaces verts en
effet mais là il faudra des pauvres des
propositions concrètes il faudra dire où
exactement finances et comment pour quel
type de de vie en commun au sein de nos
square mais je souhaite au delà de la
question de la préservation des zones
pavillonnaires qu'on soit capable de
d'accueillir de nouvelles populations
dans les crèches dans les écoles de
façon convenable est sûre cela ça
suppose qu'on cesse de bétonner
excessivement il nous reste encore deux
grandes zones à urbaniser la zac
freyssinet en bout de ville en frontière
de montigny est également les terrains
de météo france qui sont du côté du
quartier de jean macé sur ces deux
terrains nous porterons des projets
d'écoquartiers qui permettront de faire
la part belle aux espaces verts
justement nouvelle structure municipale
pour accueillir la population et nous
veillerons à faire en sorte que les
trappistes est de l'espace pour respirer
y compris au sein des squares historique
au quartier dans le quartier des
merisiers la zac de l'aérostat nous
avons là des populations différentes
nouvelles anciennes qui vivent en hlm ou
qui sont propriétaires qui doivent
partager ensemble de grands espaces
verts mon projet sur ce plan là sera
détaillé précis et près du gymnase
maillé par exemple nous porterons un
grand projet de ludo parcs des espaces
de jardins partagés pour les habitants
pour qu'ils puissent grandir ensemble et
les enfants qui grandissent attrape
qu'il soit enfin de propriétaire ou
enfants de locataires qui mal engagée
vous passez la parole je saute manas
routier réagir oui parce que je vois
bien qu'ils attaquent personnel qui
commence déjà à se dessiner dans ce
débat moi j'aimerais rappeler à monsieur
ramé que j'habitais traps et des
réalités qu'il était encore élu à poissy
et donc je n'ai aucune leçon à recevoir
ces aucune leçon c'est vraiment la sonas
pour dire qu'on peut les écouter leur
l'autre et chacun votre tour de jouer
mais sur appel pour sa part depuis des
années mais n'avait jamais
je suis ravi les jeunes lui à ce que
vous soyez honnête il assure que des
trappistes répondait ensuite livrer des
ballons très heureux de vous accueillir
chez moi ce soir après le débat pour
discuter mais je suis passé les
auditions
la réalité c'est précisément dans le
quartier où j'habite à jaurès monsieur
rabéa voté à un projet de construction
de 145 logements avec monsieur malanda
pas plus tard qu'au mois de novembre
dernier
donc par pitié ne pas manquer de respect
aux électeurs c'est aussi parler à leur
intelligence et ne pas les prendre pour
des idiots
oui il faut arrêter la bétonisation et
je suis heureux qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde soit sur cette position mais il
faut mettre en cohérence ses paroles et
ses actes
dim à l'ombre c'est à vous à présent
revenir peut-être à spa sur ce qui s'est
dit sur les constructions sur
l'urbanisation de cette ville de trappes
ces dernières années vit sur vos projets
aussi pour la suite mirabel disais tout
à l'heure il ya encore des projets à
venir notamment dans le diable de l'eau
viennent l'opération d'intérêt national
paris-saclay aller j'y vais mais merci
beaucoup
le liste on ne peut pas porter de
jugement sur une ville quand on connaît
pas son histoire
c'est pour ça que je disais tout à
l'heure moi je connais cette ville
depuis 1969
ce qu'il n'y ait pas un succès c'est une
réalité physique et elle était l est est
en panne et et quand on avait besoin de
déménager je pense par exemple à tout ce
qu'on appelait la zac monfort le long de
la rue de montfort l'ensemble des
pavillons qui est là il fallait c'est
mon expression jouer du violon
promoteurs pour trouver un promoteur qui
accepte tout ça est qui et qui viennent
nous avons comment dire avancer assez
vite de façon dé façon très très positif
à mes yeux voilà avec toute la
rénovation urbaine et le nombre de
logements qui ont été rénovés démoli et
reconstruit de notre nature
les parcs aménagés etc et puis la zai de
l'aéro ca de 2 de mon point de vue mais
de ma volonté politique aussi
en ce qui concerne les mauriciens ont
secoué la plaine de neuf j'ai déjà dit
ça x fois c'est terminé maintenant
on est dedans on est dans le détail est
la chose la plus importante qu'on va
construire c'est une résidence autonomie
et intergénérationnelle pour les
personnes âgées je pense que on peut pas
rappelé à bétonner ce serait quand même
incompréhensible par les personnes qui
qui attendent après nous nous sommes
dans une phase qui s'impose et qui est
complexe et complexes à gérer qui est
jeudi sur le l'envi de devenir dans ce
qu'on appelle le quartier diar jaurès
dans le cache pas les réalités c'est les
réalités où on avait les mélange
d'immeubles de tavillons etc
enfin certains un certain désordre
urbanistique
on a dans notre paix lui que j'avais
voté contre à la mairie pour la
communauté d'agglomération leveaux et
désiré c'est pas le ballon au fond de
ballons au fond du problème
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés je ne
le cache pas nous sommes confrontés à
une résistance à la promotion
immobilière et donc on a organisé trois
éléments et
et parce que le droit c'est le droit si
monsieur dupont vos jambes sont sa
maison y vend sa maison et donc on a
organisé trois éléments pour décaler de
façon méthodique et non pas tout le
fleuve comme ça les demandes de
construction dans le quartier gare bon
ça s'appelle l'augmentation de la taxe
d'aménagement ça s'appelle liberté qu'on
est en train de monter avec la
communauté puisque je rappelle quand
même que le l'urbanisme est une une
compétence communautaire ça s'appelle
l'opération coeur de ville et etc je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails et
donc notre volonté aujourd'hui les
éléments qu'on a mis en place y compris
des réserves de terrains sur lesquels il
est cette zone sont maintenant d'après
après la réforme du pays lui il ya deux
mois trois mois ne sont plus
constructibles sauf pour des équipements
publics parce que il y en a certaines
qui sont à côté des d'équipements
d'équipements publics voilà après on a
deux grands de grands projets internes
je termine mais je m'excuse mais si bien
sûr je je je termine après on nous avons
deux opérations elles ont l'intérêt des
des opérations d'intérêt national excusé
mais répéter le mot intérêts ça veut
dire qu on les maîtrise elles sont
gérées par l'établissement public paris
saclay et nous sommes là en capacité de
nous dire c'est pour plus tard
et moi ce que j'ai demandé dans non ma
fonction c'est que on qu'on ne commence
pas autant de raisons pour lesquelles on
pourra pas le faire d'ailleurs m'enfin
politiquement qu'on ne commence pas
le côté frais signer avec montée ni
d'ailleurs c'est un cheval sur trappe et
monty et le côté météo avant cinq ans
parce que ça nous on pouvait pas digéré
cette évolution là il ya un accord il ya
un accord là dessus donc c'est chose
réparée à dire après sur les autres les
autres sujets avira b pardon excusez moi
c'est à vous souhaitez réagir aussi un
élément je disais nous et guy malandain
vient de l'évoquer rapidement nos écoles
nos crèches sont déjà saturées il y à un
second enjeu c'est de faire vivre
ensemble les habitants qui sont
historiquement implanté attraper ceux
qui arrivent notamment les jeunes
couples qui viennent et qui font des
enfants
c'est un enjeu essentiel parce que chez
la population trappistes qui les a ce
sentiment juste ou non que une partie
des nouvelles arrivées conduisent les
anciens à être marginalisées dans la
ville ou à devoir quitter la ville donc
il ya cet enjeu très fort de faire en
sorte que les anciens quartiers
d'habitations à loyer modéré les
logements sociaux cohabitent de façon
harmonieuse avec les nouveaux habitants
qui arrivent et qui parfois ont des
revenus plus importants paye par exemple
la taxe foncière comme propriétaire
c'est mon cas et faire en sorte que ces
générations grandissent ensemble c'est
vraiment le défi des prochaines années
trappes a été considérablement
transformé il faut d'ailleurs rendre
hommage à guy maddin pour ce travail
mais on s'est beaucoup occupé des
bâtiments dans les années qui viennent
il faudra qu'on s'occupe davantage des
gens c'est sur ce travail particulier qu
avec les trappistes puisque nous avons
travaillé en ateliers citoyens nous
avons cherché à proposer un programme
concret précis et financer très
rapidement on a aussi quelques éléments
parce que encore une fois j'entends ce
qu'il dit et je rappelle qu'on a une
équipe qui est aux responsabilités il
faut qu'on voie ce qui marche et ce qui
ne marche pas en l'occurrence on parlait
à l'instant des crèches qui est un vrai
sujet aussi sur la ville de trappes
effectivement ça ne sert à rien de faire
du logement si on ne fait pas ce qui va
avec le mans je constate qu'aujourd'hui
sur très rapidement que 500 places de
crèche pour être dans la moyenne des
villes des civils c'est la réalité
aujourd'hui de la gestion municipale
actuelle non c est donc celle que le
taux de couverture des besoins de 34% la
voyais pas ce qui est largement sur
je répondis tous les deux à la fois bon
sens ils vont donc mais je comprends
mieux que vous ayez voté six ans il
manque
il manque 500 places de crèche nous nous
engageons sur les 300 places de crèche
parce que nous ne pourrons pas faire
plus sur le mandat il faut être crédible
surtout d'avoir la capacité de financer
les choses parce que sinon toutes les
belles paroles n'ont que peu de valeur
et moi je parle ici avec le soutien de
l'agglomération du département et de la
région ile de france c'est nous qui
avons par exemple sur un autre sujet qui
concerne l'urbanisme le fait que nous
n'ayons plus de médecins généralistes
sur tout un quartier de 12000 habitants
quels quartiers jaurès
le fait qu'on ait perdu 30 % de médecins
généralistes en se disant là aussi c'est
un constat d'échec et il faut qu'on
trouve des solutions
il a fallu que ce soit la région qui
finance une maison de santé de pour 260
milles euros à trappes sans que la ville
mette un seul euro donc moi je veux bien
entendre qu'il faut que maintenant tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut lever le pied sur la bétonisation
et qu'il faut faire le reste
mais encore une fois il faut être
cohérent il faut voir la capacité de
financer ses projets crèche commerce
santé malanda vous m'aviez demandé la
parole juste juste avant alesi et puis
après ce sera au tour d'ali rabais mais
allez-y brièvement malandain oui je veux
j'entends ce que dit monsieur n'à
through mais j'approuve pas du tout
parce que c'est pas ces laissez pas la
réalité
nous sommes une des rares villes sur la
santé qui a une maison de santé dont on
vient de doubler les deux doubles et les
les médecins les nos écoles sur lesquels
on travaille beaucoup on vient de
refaire feu l'école jules ferry on va
maintenant faire l'école flaubert et ses
terres et ses répondent à la nécessité
et il est et restera donc au niveau des
équipements publics je pense franchement
que nous sommes c'est jamais s'est
jamais suffisant je sais bien mais nous
sommes pas nous ne sommes pas en retard
après il ya le sujet qui a été abordé
par monsieur rabais qui est qu il
comment le vit comment on vit ensemble
quand on est ancien et quand on est
nouveau harry arrivant dans dans un
quartier je rappelle que quand même dans
les acquisitions de la zac violet rossa
40% sont des habitants de trappes et il
ya un autre élément que je veux mettre
comme ça sur la trame voilà et est ce
que est ce que vous savez combien il y a
deux demandes de logement social à
trappes non 5500 demande de logement
social il nous avons sept mille deux
cents logements sociaux 7200 exactement
sept mille deux cents logements sociaux
est donc comme on est en agglomération
une des conditions de vie je termine pas
ça parce que comme on est en
agglomération et on a vu ces ces
discussions dans le cadre du programme
local de l'habitat et cetera il faut
accueillir tous ces personnes là qui
sont en attente d'un logement pour des
raisons de vie quotidienne et ça ne peut
pas tout ne peut pas se faire attraper
et on ne peut pas demander à trappes de
faire toujours plus et ils rattrapent ni
personne il faut savoir extra minutes un
mail avance au savoir conduire et y
répondre à des réalités c'est vrai ou
c'est faux nous en béton non pas nous
avons fait transformer la ville pour
qu'elle soit plus agréable vous aviez en
deux temps et on ne voudrait pas
vraiment je veux je vous coupe parce que
sinon vous ne pourrez endroits que vous
entendre sur les autres sujets voilà
vous êtes à plus de 9 minutes les autres
à en dessous des 5 minutes 30
maintenant la balle c'est à vous comme
vous le souhaitez je souhaite juste que
l'équité sera respectée
vous le savez bien sûr les crèches c'est
un élément extrêmement important de
l'avenir de trappes parce qu'on est une
ville qui fait beaucoup d'enfants la
moitié des habitants de travaux moins de
29 ans donc vous voyez quelle dynamique
démographique est à l'oeuvre attraper
c'est une bonne nouvelle
il faut donner des chiffres précis et
juste et d'ailleurs ces chiffres sont va
facilement vérifiable c'est la caisse
d'allocations familiales qui donne les
chiffres les plus transparents les plus
et c'est la caisse d'allocations
familiales qui finance les places de
crèche essentiellement en investissement
comment fonctionne la caisse
d'allocations familiales indique attrape
nous sommes à 40 % de taux de couverture
le taux de couverture c'est le nombre de
berceaux par rapport au nombre de bébés
qui naissent à trappes
donc on n'est pas 30 ou 31 % on est à 40
% c'est le chiffre
verdict attendu mais les informations
sont pas publiques les sites internet
l'occurrence 710 yona la séance de
baisse beaucoup de monde ça fait garder
votre calme
j'ai parfaitement galonnés les sources
précises et vous vérifier immédiatement
en sortant de cette émission est
d'ailleurs ceux qui nous écoutent
également on est à 40 % de taux de
couverture attrape ce qui est
insuffisant très long très en dessous de
la moyenne et celle d'egypte vérifier ce
week end encore sur le site internet de
la caisse d'allocations familiales des
yvelines ouvriers et pas plus de
transparence et public sur saint quentin
en yvelines nous sommes à 60 %
donc vous voyez qu'il ya un retard
considérable qui n'est pas 500 places
comme l'indiquent othman merci mais qui
est 2 potentiellement autour de 200
places ce qui est beaucoup et qu'il faut
rattraper
donc là il faut être honnête il faut
être honnête avec les électeurs parce
que si on propose deux ratés de raser
gratis
on va se préparer des lendemains qui
déchantent attrape construire une crèche
supplémentaires c'est faisable c'est
finançable construire 300 places de
crèche
demain matin c'est faux c'est un
mensonge et personne ne pourra le faire
ni othman la chronique et malandain ni
moi même donc je ne m'engagerai pas dans
une promesse que je ne pourrais pas
tenir
en revanche nous créerons une centaine
de places supplémentaires dont une
crèche collective de 60 berceaux
c'est le programme que nous portons et
c'est largement finançable mais si on
dit qu'on baisse les impôts d'une part
c'est ce que propose monsieur n'à seront
en baissant la taxe foncière de 10
points de 10% pardo et si d'autre part
on dit qu'on créé 300 places de crèche
c'est incompatible le projet d'autres
magnats seront projet de guy malandain
je ne le connais pas encore un détail
pour ce qui concerne le projet d'autres
menaces rouge et demandé un directeur
financier de collectivités locales de
l'évaluer et d'évaluer également le mien
je ferai le même exercice avec le projet
de gym à londres pour ce qui concerne
mon projet j'estime les dépenses
nouvelles dont cette fameuse crèches
supplémentaires 2,1 millions d'euros en
fonctionnement
je n'évoque l'acculent socialement dire
qu'on baisse les impôts de 10 % ça veut
dire que l'on perd en recettes un
million deux cent mille euros
dès l'année prochaine dire que l'on
construit 300 places de crèche ça veut
dire qu'on fonctionnement on s'engage
sur des dépenses à plus de 2 millions
d'euros
dire que l'on va tripler les effectifs
de la police municipale moi je propose
de les doubler vous voyez je suis pas
idéologiquement désaccord avec
l'augmentation des effectifs mais dire
qu'on augmente à 30 postes équivalent
temps plein les effectifs de la police
municipale s'est dépensé un million et
demi supplémentaires tous ces chiffres
sont vérifiées précisées par un
spécialiste du financement des
collectivités locales
donc vous avez là un projet à six
lyon d'euros et je les cimes au bas mot
parce que je n'ai pas intégrer un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont
impossibles à évaluer puisqu'elles sont
trop imprécises dans le programme de
monsieur natrue moi je respecte ce que
vous dites est ce que vous proposez mais
je vous demande de faire un exercice
honnête sincère et réaliste vis-à-vis
des électeurs parce que si vous allez à
l'élection municipale pour perdre et
pour promettre c'est un choix mais je
pense qu'il n'est pas noble
moi je suis candidat à cette élection
pour gagner cette addiction et donc je
sais j'assumerai chacune des
propositions que je porte je l'évaluent
financièrement je sais comment financer
ces mesures est donc je m'engage sur un
programme réalisable à lire abel guy
malandain vous êtes au tour 9 minutes ce
qui n'est pas le cas d'autres menaces
roux 5 minutes 30 vous avez largement
temps de réagir et après j'aimerais
qu'on évoque même si vous avez largement
contribué à faire avancer ce débat en
évoquant aussi le cadre de vie notamment
mais conviennent aussi sur les
conditions de vie au sein de ces
logements et comprennent un temps avant
de passer à une autre thématique est
notamment l'éducation et on parlera de
sécurité à la fin du à la fin du débat
donc maintenant si vous souhaitez déjà
réagir sur ce qui s'est dit oui beaucoup
de choses alors je suis déjà heureux que
le débat se fasse sur mon projet sur le
projet que nous portons puisque c'est
essentiellement de cela dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure ce projet il est
là et il sait le ce projet aujourd'hui
qui est sur la place publique et
distribuer aux trappistes et je trouve
quand même incroyable que ce soit
l'opposition qui aujourd'hui est un
projet et que je ne fais pas encore le
projet de nos candidats en tout cas il
n'a pas été que milk est vrai bac 2
rompu monsieur rabais de réunion
monsieur vous répondre
la réalité c'est que sur la question du
financement je suis le seul aujourd'hui
être en capacité de financer un projet
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne porte plus
des projets avec uniquement le budget
d'une ville
il faut des partenaires et je crains que
demain au contraire avec cette équipe
municipale actuelle la ville n'ait plus
accès à un certain nombre de
financements qui sont ceux encore une
fois de la région du département et
l'agglomération
on a rénové le lycée mathy ça a coûté 12
millions d'euros ces mots qui est
partiellement nature qui l'a voté
monsonis il faut élever la gare de
travers a coûté neuf millions fonds de
roulement personnellement d'annulation
pression de la goutelle et rapidement sa
pensée par a écouté et respecté
contradicteurs vous plaît vous n'êtes
pas adhérent ne vous ai pas je ne vous
tromperez pas si vous ne faites pas de
contre vérités mais là il va bien
trouver un lien c'est ma part pour moi
qui vais avoir besoin pour la section et
barbier fischer qu'ils ont voté et
financer avant même que vous soyez
conseil régional monsieur malige entendu
le message et monsieur la parole après
fait heureux de vous annoncer que nous
allons débloquer 8 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour la rénovation de la
cantine du lycée de la plaine de nos
flux en avait bien besoin que la
présente majorité avait promis depuis
2006 et tu ne sais jamais fait ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que quand on est
crédible compétents et sérieux il n'y a
pas de raison qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
attraper ce que les autres villes
arrivent à faire parce que je sache
qu'on attrape une taxe foncière qui est
20% plus élevé que les villes voisines
et je constate que monsieur rabé ne le
conteste pas mais il a voté
systématiquement cette taxe foncière
pendant six années sans sourciller
aujourd'hui la trouve trop élevé je
propose de l'abaisser pas de 20% ce ne
serait pas réaliste simplement de 10%
pour la rapprocher du niveau des villes
voisines pour le reste quand on parle
des dépenses qui sont dans notre projet
je tiens à préciser que la ville de
trappes aujourd'hui fait 5 millions
d'euros d'excédent de fonctionnement
tous les ans c'est à dire que c'est un
argent qui n'est pas utilisé au service
des habitants et qu' il ya tout un tas
de ressources nouvelles qu'elle ne va
pas chercher je donne un exemple sur la
police municipale car effectivement il
faut tripler la police municipale pour
qu'elle fonctionne 24 heures sur 24
c'est le seul moyen pour elle fonctionne
24 heures sur 24 ce qui me prive de
proximité dont on a besoin
mais la région ile-de-france a un budget
en matière de sécurisation des villes
pourquoi la ville de trappes n'a jamais
fait la moindre demande en six ans je
n'ai cessé de le proposer
pourquoi est ce que quand il s'agit de
rénover le square jules védrines qui
était dans un état lamentable on va
parler de logements dans un instant il a
fallu que soit le département qui qui
développe le million d'euros
supplémentaires pour boucler le
financement de cette opération
de l'argent il y en a simplement il faut
des élus compétents crédible rassembleur
qui vont aller le chercher et qui savent
l'utiliser alors tout ce qu'ils
m'expliquent que ce n'est pas possible
alors que d'autres villes le font
moi je me souviens que quand on accouche
confier la responsabilité de propofol
on m'avait dit la même chose on m'avait
dit c'est au bord de la faillite il n'y
a rien à faire
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est une structure
qui est désendetter qui vient de
réaliser son meilleur résultat depuis
plus de trente ans donc pardon c'est pas
parce que certains ne savent pas le
faire que ce n'est pas faisable
le projet qui est sur la table est le
seul projet cohérent concret et crédible
et surtout constant dans le temps et en
capacité d'être financés par nos
partenaires
lear avait je vous passe la parole mais
c'est juste sur un point notamment vous
souhaitiez réagir c'était sur les deux
bouts en passant sur la botte de la taxe
foncière sur les impôts il fallait qu'on
soit précis qu'on soit honnête monsieur
n'à through déplore l'augmentation
d'impôts de taxes foncières qui a été
décidée effectivement par la majorité
actuelle
savez vous obtenez une observatoire
l'adjoint de monsieur malanda monsieur
rap et moi je je suis raide she s
avez-vous de combien a été augmentée
l'un moi je suis assez juste que je ne
suis pas candidat attrape question donc
j'aurai beaucoup moins la réponse que
vous 3g spli contribuables trappistes
moi je paye la taxe d'habitation et je
paie que sa taxe foncière la taxe
foncière à plusieurs par d'ailleurs la
part communale qui a augmenté la part
départementale les amis politiques de
monsieur nasro sent qu'il est ne les
désavoue jamais augmenté non pas de 10 %
n'ont pas de 20% de 60 % la part de la
taxe foncière en 2014 est ce que vous
savez pour moi ont tristement j'ai fait
le calcul je vous parle en comparaison
des vivres du mérite de mourir avec
l'avion de trappes
moi je compare mon médecin pour j je
vous demande pas de le faire assez ou
vous risquez pas ce que vont arrêter ces
sujets-là attrape de taxes foncières
d'évoquer la la taxe foncière je paye
dorénavant 300 euros supplémentaires de
taxes foncières
chaque année l'augmentation taxe
d'habitation décidés par la majorité
actuelle avec guy malandain qui est tout
à fait qui permet de financer des
projets qui profitent aux trappistes ça
nous coûte 140 euros supplémentaires
chaque année
donc le département dirigé par les amis
de monsieur nasri ne ponctionne deux
fois plus que l'augmentation de taxes
foncières arabe et qui vont venir
écouter projet de jeu sera effectivement
ravi d'aller finir tout cela et on pas
l'édifice de style gens à parler des
enjeux sur trappe et vouloir y en a
beaucoup
j'aimerais qu'on ait le temps quand même
au cours de ce débat d'aborder l
éducation et la sécurité aussi parce que
ça revient beaucoup dans les différentes
discussions vous pouvez avoir même si
des thèmes il y en a beaucoup et je
rappelle que vous pouvez aussi si vous
êtes électeur sur trappe ou pas si ça
vous intéresse aussi vous rendre dans
les meetings des uns et des autres et
consulter les programmes et vous aurez
tous les éléments
à disposition pour faire votre choix
pour le premier tour du scrutin le 15
mars sur le logement plus spécifiquement
on vous a vu les uns les autres
intervenir aussi sur le terrain auprès
des bailleurs sociaux
j'aurais nous donne juste quelques
éléments il ya plus de onze mille
logements sur tra plus de 60 % de
logements sociaux la commune fait partie
des villes des yvelines qui en compte le
plus
et certains de ces logements sont dans
une situation d'insalubrité réels
espions les comme ça aujourd'hui comment
si vous êtes élu vous allez pouvoir
intervenir et auprès des bailleurs
sociaux pour que ces logements et que
les habitants en tout cas et des
meilleures conditions de vie on commence
avec votre mana soit les choses sont là
dessus assez simple puisque ça fait six
années que nous abordons ce sujet de la
qualité du logement
et là je ne vais pas m'adresser monsieur
arabe et qui toujours l'adjoint de
monsieur vendanges viendrait directement
du coup un monsieur malandain parce
qu'en fait aujourd'hui n'y a que deux
choix clair dans cette élection et je
n'ai jamais compris et je le dis très
tranquillement pourquoi ce sujet a été
délaissé par la municipalité
conte et attrapes gelé vécu puisque
c'est moi qui ai dû intervenir une
famille par exemple square il farges
avec une enfant malade pendant un an des
moisissures un logement totalement
insalubre et personne qui répond au
courrier je n'ai vu personne de l'équipe
municipale se déplacer il a fallu que le
jeu viennent avec le vice-président de
la région charges de logement et la
presse pour obtenir un logement ça
marche et cette fois ci ça n'a pas
marché d'autrefois
on a un niveau de charges dans le parc
social de trappes qui parfois prohibitif
sans qu'il y ait de contrôle des charges
avec des sur provisions on a des
bailleurs qui ne respectent pas toujours
leurs obligations légales d'entretien et
de réparation au moment où je vous parle
allez des yvelines il y as depuis quatre
mois des problèmes de chauffage qui sont
inacceptables sans que personne ne bouge
pendant six ans il a fallu que ce soit
l'élu d'opposition que je suis alors que
ce n'est pas ma responsabilité qui
essayé d'alerter et et de simplement
d'obtenir que les locataires puissent
défendre leur droit le plus légitime à
partir du moment où ils payent
évidemment aussi leur loyer alors moi
j'entends bien que encore une forte
il est des débats sur les étiquettes et
j'entends que mes adversaires ont tous
les deux le coeur à gauche moi je
constate que sur ce sujet ils ont
surtout les yeux fermés parce que ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans le logement
social à trappes est inacceptable et
demain je le dis très clairement la
municipalité grâce à une cellule d'aidé
juridique et grâce à une action qui
détaillait dans notre projet eh bien ce
sera aux côtés des locataires qui
malanda sur cette question des logements
et des conditions de vie
des habitants leur pays comme dans tout
le domaine quand je suis dans la tribune
je joue toujours mieux que celui qui est
sur le terrain et sur ça il ya des
vérités et il y a il ya aussi
heureusement sur des contre-vérités sur
les sept mille deux cents logements
sociaux nous avons dans certains dans
certains secteurs des difficultés
importantes
quant à la tenue et c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle on fait je pense à
cabu en particulier pour lesquelles on
fait une deuxième rénovation urbaine
c'est que l'âge la durée enfin
d'ancienneté de ces logements là ne
convient pas les interventions sur les
logements pour la ligier n la propreté
la sécurité et cetera quand je suis au
marché toutes les semaines je reviens
avec dix ou quinze demandes de rendez
vous je fais je fais ces dix et quinze
demandes de rendez vous et toutes ses
interventions auprès des bailleurs
je rencontre parfois à la place d'aider
des gens pour les aider les difficultés
extrêmement importante pas parler de
certains d'ailleurs ici ce serait
malvenu sont pas la peau ils sont là
pour répondre mais il y en a qui ne gère
pas le qu'ils ne gèrent pas leurs leur
patrimoine et donc non mais un service
logement un service hygiène un
engagement du maire il aurait dû y avoir
un engagement de la joie mais ça c'est
un autre problème on va pleurer il est
maintenant je reçois je vous le dis en
entre 10 et 15 personnes pour des
problèmes de logement et tgv voie ne
fait pas photographiées par la presse
locale je vais voir et suivre les gens
et c'est une réalité que objective qui
lie à sur la ville sur les 7000
logements sociaux je compte a à peu près
entre 250 et 300 logements qui
ne sont pas en état suffit suffisant et
dont dont donc d'ong locales but qui
fait les 300 logements et qui va être
démoli rénové en forme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on a réglé ce ajouté alors on
prend conscience cette réalité moi je la
connais voilà j'en avais de rendez vous
avant de venir ici sur ce sujet là on
peut pas comme ça à faire la pichenette
moi je m'en occupe la commune ne s'en
occupe a séparé mes prédécesseurs et des
prédécesseurs à monsieur parce que mes
prédécesseurs s'en occupait aussi bien
qu'on ait eu des différends et etc
c'est extrêmement compliqué et je peux
ajouter quelque chose parce que ça nous
intéresse tous les tous les trois la lah
pour le futur on ne sait jamais on sait
le lendemain on sait jamais la veille et
d'un voeu comment dire l'élargissement
de débats your ass eu à se regrouper
pour obtenir six logements richard a
fait que les j'allais dire les petits
bailleurs qui gérait soigneusement leurs
propriétés qu'on essaie leur leurs
locataires etc se sont vus rassemblé 1
il ya trois quatre bailleurs qui sont
devenus par exemple céder ses habitats
mais maintenant c'est une grosse
opération et c'est difficile d'avoir des
contacts concrets au quotidien je le
regrette cette situation là parce que si
vous le savez j'ai jeté un coup d'oeil
le logement ça a été une de mes passions
pendant dix ans à l'assemblée nationale
il ya encore des traces à lire mais
c'est avant en deux minutes si vous
pouviez revenir sur ce point là et après
on passera un autre sujet l'éducation a
sur ce point j'ai l'insigne totalement
j'engagerai le bras de fer avec un
certain nombre de bailleurs qui ne
respectent pas leurs obligations aux
menaces qu'on se déplace avec les
caméras et des élus de la région
ile-de-france moi cette semaine encore
sans caméra sans élus de la région il
doctement seul moyen âge gt gt dans deux
logements insalubres pour les visiter
avec le service logement de la ville de
trappes pour mesurer pour constater
l'insalubrité faire un procès verbal et
pouvoir adresser injonction aux
bailleurs de respecter ses obligations
des mesures concrètes parce que n'est
pas là pour faire des commentaires sur
ce que les uns et les autres font devant
les caméras de télé le les compétences
du maire doivent être complètement
porter en matière de lutte contre
l'insalubrité et ça suppose que demain
on soit capable d'appliquer des amendes
en faisant respecter les règlements des
préfectoral de lutte contre la sent la
salubrité cela supposera donc qu'on
applique des ailes des amendes et qu'on
les applique de façon dissuasive pour
les bailleurs se met à faire leur
travail
les taper au portefeuille il faudra
également qu'on soit capable de
renforcer le service logement de la
ville de trappes
aujourd'hui il n'y a qu'une seule
personne qui s'occupe de la lutte contre
l'insalubrité
quand on a 300 logements à visiter quand
on a 300 procès verbaux à réaliser il
faudra trois ou quatre personnes à plein
temps chargé uniquement de dresser ces
procès verbaux de visiter les logements
moi j'entends dire qu'il ya des
logements qu'on met en location sur
lequel on envoie des futurs locataires
et qui sont totalement insalubres qui
sont refusés pour cause d'insalubrité
il faudra également c'est une faute des
bailleurs effectivement les justes guy
je pense une proposition que tu pourrais
aussi reprenant ton programme moi je
partage
c'est l'idée de dire que plus aucun
logement n'est remis sur le marché de la
location loi sans qu'un agent municipal
sans qu'un agent municipal n'est visité
le logement pour vérifier son état de
salubrité ce n'est malheureusement pas
fait aujourd'hui moi je soutiendrai les
amicales de locataires très fortement y
compris financièrement et juridiquement
nous engagerons également un contrôle
annuel de charges portées par la
municipalité en lien avec les amicales
de locataires pour le systématiser que
ça ne dépendent pas que du bon goût
de tels ou tels amical ou de ses moyens
mais ce sera porté par la ville
elle-même et nous mettrons à disposition
nos juristes et nos moyens financiers
enfin quelque chose de relativement
puissant que le maire pourrait mobiliser
c'est tout simplement de réaliser les
travaux quand les bailleurs ne refuse de
le faire aujourd'hui les pouvoirs du
maire lui permettent
si le bailleur refuse de réaliser les
travaux qui figure dans le procès verbal
dressé par le service en charge de
l'insalubrité
alors le maire peut dans ses pouvoirs de
police réaliser les travaux et exiger
ensuite du fisc de se faire rembourser
par les bailleurs c'est un instrument
juridique qui existe chacun pourra le
vérifier que la mairie peut mobiliser et
je terminerai parce que on évoque les
bailleurs beaucoup les bailleurs sociaux
il ya également des propriétaires privés
à trappes il ya des marchands de sommeil
qui utilisent leur patrimoine privé pour
le louer à des gens souvent dans la
détresse sans l'entretenir et à des
loyers prohibitifs
demain nous appliquerons une nouvelle
disposition de la loi est lent et de la
loi allure qui permet d'instaurer le
permis de louer la municipalité avant
d'autoriser la mise en location d'un
bien pourra vérifier qu'il est salubre
juste a ajouté que le permis le permis
de louer il est en cours de fabrication
et il le permis de louer il est en cours
de fabrication c'est un outil très très
intéressant et qu'on doit faire avec
deux autres villes
excusez-moi de vous et à la commune aux
oublieux qu'on doit faire avec deux
autres villes de la communauté
d'agglomération voilà et c'est un outil
très très très utile mais je m'occuperai
de le mettre en place
oui d'abord j'aimerais rappeler à mr
malandain et monsieur rabais qui sont
tous les deux responsabilités depuis six
ans dont je suis très heureux d'entendre
maintenant ce soir ce que nous demandons
depuis six ans en 2014 nous avions
déposé un voeu conseil municipal qui
reprend exactement tout ce qui vient
d'être dit sur le contrôle des charges
sur la mise en demeure des bailleurs sur
l'entretien la réparation et à l'époque
mais c'est mal aux doigts comme sur abel
voté contre se veut et donc approcher
favon dirait on vous enverra nos
propositions à l'avancé au moins
l'essentiel c'est que les idées avance
parce que les locataires ont été
délaissés pendant plusieurs années et ça
a été à l'opposition de s'en saisir ce
qui n'était pas normale et encore une
fois et nous n'avons pas pu régler un
certain nombre de difficultés qui
persistent aujourd'hui voilà ce que je
souhaitais partager avec vous parce que
c'est un sujet vraiment important et au
moment où je vous parle il ya une
habitante d'albert camus j'ai sollicité
monsieur malandain à ce sujet mais
j'imagine que mr abe qui a la compétence
aussi
désormais sur cette délégation a eu
copie de ce courrier qui attend toujours
un logement depuis deux ans elle est en
situation de handicap suite à un
traumatisme crânien elle habite
d'ailleurs qu'à lui et elle ne l'est au
troisième étage sans ascenseur elle ne
peut pas elle ne peut pas sortir de chez
elle et là ma connaissance personne ne
lui a encore répondu au moment où je
vous parle c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres je ne dis pas d'ailleurs je
n'accuse personne mais y avoir aussi les
services qui ne font pas passer
l'information mais il faut absolument
qu'on reçoit beaucoup plus pro actif
parce que quand une fois là il s'agit
d'une vraie souffrance individuelle
personnelle d'un certain nombre de
famille à trappes
le débat se poursuit sur tv soit 118 si
vous nous suivez aussi sur radio
sensations concerne la ville de trappes
passons à l'éducation c'est l'une des
missions principales du maire ce pour ça
qu'on va s'y attarder on va voir vos
propositions il ya plusieurs sujets sur
cette question de l'éducation on
pourrait parler là du rythme scolaire
quatre jours quatre jours et demi chacun
les uns les autres sont positionnés dans
leur programme pour revenir ou non à
l'ancien rite nous laisser celui qui a
été mis en place sur la ville de trappes
et puis il ya d'autres projets aussi
intra pas obtenu en septembre dernier le
label de cité éducative qui permet aussi
une stratégie territoriale pour
accompagner la réussite des jeunes de 3
à 25 ans l éducation thème important
pour les habitants de trappes aussi on
va débuter avec votre manager vous avez
un petit peu plus de retard par rapport
aux deux autres candidats oui la réalité
c'est que sur la question de l'école on
a perdu beaucoup de temps depuis 2014
d'abord sur la question des rythmes
scolaires ou en refusant d'écouter la
communauté éducative
l'équipe municipale actuelle depuis six
années s'est entêté à rester sur un
rythme scolaire de quatre jours et demi
ce qui a beaucoup d organiser le
fonctionnement des activités
périscolaires et nous nous réclamons
depuis six années maintenant encore une
fois le retour à la semaine de quatre
jours comme 87 % des communes l'ont fait
je constate qu'à des positions là aussi
qui évolue à un mois des élections mais
six années d'entêtement ça a été six
années de perdues et avec ingres une
grande souffrance des parents d'élèves
et des enseignants avec un dialogue qui
n'est absolument pas aujourd'hui au
niveau où il devrait être
avec la municipalité il s'agit bien sûr
de remettre aussi leur d'études qui a
été supprimés en 2015 le 22 juin 2015 au
conseil municipal je m'en souviendrai
toujours puisque les parents d'élèves
étaient venus manifester que là aussi il
avait été le seul candidat à voter
contre cette suppression de leurs
d'études ça a été terrible
ça a été terrible puisque ça a fait que
nous avons aujourd'hui 1500 enfant de
trappes qui sont dehors à 15h30 tous les
jours alors que c'était de devoir qui
était gratuite était absolument utile et
conviennent pas venir là aussi que c'est
une question de financement ce qui était
possible avant 2015
est toujours possible aujourd'hui et
puis bien sûr il faut qu'on améliore le
niveau scolaire en améliorant d'abord à
la qualité des activités périscolaires
là aussi j'entends qu'il faudrait les
rendre toutes gratuites je crois que
c'est une je crois que c'est une erreur
que la question est celle de la
tarification la cantine des activités
périscolaires qui est mal proportionné
c'est pour ça que je vote contre à
chaque fois tout les encore une fois je
suis le seul parce qu'il faut de la
cohérence la sincérité de la crédibilité
sur ce type de sujet parce que ce sont
des sujets qui ne se règle pas du jour
au lendemain et je je je sais qu'un
travail important est fait aussi par
l'éducation nationale par les
enseignants qui sont très mobilisés mais
je constate que la municipalité n'a pas
fait le nécessaire n'a pas fait le
maximum comme d'autres villes pour que
les conditions d'apprentissage soient
les meilleurs possibles donc je vous
disais sur le contenu des activités
périscolaires
c'est vrai sur la question du numérique
sur laquelle on a pris beaucoup de
retard par rapport à d'autres villes
c'est d'ailleurs l'agglomération et le
département qui aujourd'hui met un
million d'euros sur la table c'est 70%
du coût total pour que la ville de
trappes équipe
toutes ces écoles est globalement il
faut qu'on investisse davantage sur nos
écoles qu'ils sont un projet de nouvelle
école à trappes l'école jules ferry
c'est très bien un seul projet c'est
insuffisant surtout qu'à d'autres qui
attendent d'être rénovée et on sait que
même si les budgets des collectivités
sont contraints là aussi il existe des
ressources pour investir davantage sur
les écoles voilà en quelques en quelques
lignes il y aurait encore beaucoup de
choses à dire mais là aussi il faut de
la constance du sérieux de la cohérence
et je crois que là-dessus sur la
réussite scolaire
cette équipe municipale est en échec
aujourd'hui un lit rabais c'est à vous
je vais vous demander un effort de
concision que vous ayez chacun le temps
à peu près deux minutes pour pour
conclure on n'aura pas le temps je vous
le dis tout de suite d'aborder la
question de la sécurité si vous le
souhaitez en fin d'émission dans votre
carte blanche pour les deux dernières
minutes mais en une minute une minute
trente pour résumer et réponses sur les
questions c'est compliqué
malheureusement voilà pour équilibrer le
temps de parler français principal bon
l'éducation la question des rythmes
scolaires en deux mots nous reviendrons
à la semaine de quatre jours ce n'est
pas mon choix personnel d'ailleurs je
les assume et devant les électeurs parce
que j'ai un démarche franche et honnête
vis-à-vis d'eux mais j'ai organisé dans
le cadre de la campagne électorale
un grand référendum à trappes pour
demander leur avis aux trappistes
puisque je suis interpellé moi je fais
mes courses à trappes je vais la
boulangerie au marché à trappes
régulièrement par les trappistes sur ce
sujet qui me disent à la limite que vous
soyez pour les quatre jours les quatre
jours et demi c'était une question mais
nous n'avons jamais pu nous exprimer
vraiment mais nous n'avons jamais eu le
sentiment d'avoir été
tendues les vitres vous êtes filmé suivi
à l'époque
donc là on n'a pas le temps d'en face
interne selon vous le voulez bien
moi pas s'interrompre
mais dire que en 2013 moi je n'étais
même pas élu de la ville de trappes mais
enfin tu as pris non plus lui non plus
n'était pas élu à la ville de travaux
qu'il n'a pas plus que moi votez les
quatre jours et demi s'était mise en
place avant même notre élection à nous
donc un sens s'il vous plaît nous avons
organisé un référendum plus de mille
votants ont participé un succès qui a
largement dépassé nos espérances et les
trappistes se sont exprimés à 77%
c'est la marque de fabrique de ma façon
de faire de la politique je respecterai
les engagements que j'ai pris devant les
trappistes parce qu'ils ont massivement
voté pour les quatre jours nous la
mettrons en oeuvre nous rétablirons
évidemment l'aide aux devoirs gratuite
et pour cela il existe des financements
qu'on peut mobiliser
c'est ce qui est incroyable aujourd'hui
nous passons pour la mise en oeuvre de
l'aide aux devoirs
je regrette je déplore qu'elle ait été
supprimée par la première adjointe au
maire jeanine mari la cote est de 80
milliards amélie de vote
nous passons à côté de 80000 euros de
subvention du contrat local
d'accompagnement à la scolarité
c'est l'état qui finance demain nous
irons chercher cet argent pour faire de
l'aide aux devoirs gratuit avec les
enseignants de trappes et des animateurs
diplômés
enfin sur le périscolaire le mercredi
matin oui je l'assumé tout à fait nous
mettrons en place trois heures
d'activités périscolaires de grande
qualité avec des ateliers logico
mathématique du théâtre des jeux
d'échecs pour développer des compétences
qui ne sont pas strictement scolaire
mais qui accompagne la réussite scolaire
et nous le ferons gratuitement pour que
tous les enfants aient accès sans
discrimination aucune
et sur la tarification il est temps de
revoir les tarifs nous sommes l'une des
villes où les tarifs maximums sont les
plus élevés il faut soulager les classes
moyennes aujourd'hui avec deux smic vous
payez 18 euros 50 pour la journée traite
extrascolaires on descendre à 10 euros
et le repas maximum sera à 92,1 est là
et je veux juste préciser en toute
transparence qu'il a un petit souci sur
les chronomètres missionné trouve à la
remarque est aussi et c'est pour ça
excusez moi monsieur rabais mais que
j'étais moins attentifs à ce que vous
disiez si on peut juste bloquer les les
chronomètres et remettre le temps qui
était prévu voilà on m'a dit qu'en régie
qu'ils ont également déclenché de
l'autre chronomètre toute sécurité pour
régulariser tout ça quoi qu'il en soit
monsieur malandain sans une minute
trente à peuvent revenir sur ces
questions d'éducation et vous serez à
peu près tous à temps de parole et
contractuels seraient plus de temps pour
conclure traité l'éducation de 4500
enfants et de 35 écoles en une note 30
reviendrez vous aussi ça vous ennuie pas
qu'après parce que c'est vraiment ce
c'est vraiment sommaire nous nous
resterons aux quatre jours et demi et ce
n'est pas une fantaisie c'est une
nécessité qui est étudiée par toutes les
personnes et qui est non seulement une
nécessité pédagogique pour les enfants
on n'a pas le temps d'aller jusqu'au
bout moi je citerai quelqu'un qui est
que j'ai bien connu à une certaine
époque qui fut muniz l'éducation
nationale monsieur hamon il a raison et
qui rappelle que le niveau des enfants
en français en mathématiques a reculé
sur les quinze à dix années en raison
notamment de l'organisation du temps
scolaire autour de quatre jours il avait
raison il avait raison de dire ça et je
ne continue pas je continue pas et ça
c'était quand on a discuté il était
conseiller municipal il venait d'être
milices et il avait raison
monsieur miserait qui est l'ajout raison
monsieur miserait oui mais en patience
ont été contrôlés organiserait qui
souhaite rappeler aux sikhs que la
réforme des rythmes scolaires est une
bonne réforme car elle permet de revenir
sur cette semaine de quatre jours qui
était une aberration pour l'évolution de
l'enfant et donc il y a au delà au delà
du scientifique au delà de la recherche
il y a aussi un accord politique là
dessus les quatre jours et demi c'est
beaucoup mieux pour les enfants que les
parents ils peuvent s'exprimer comme ils
l'entendent mais en tout cas nous le
gardons les quatre jours et demi
j'ajoute qui a un problème qui nous
dépasse tous les trois et si on termine
là dessus ça me paraît positif les
enfants c'est pas un jouet c'est s'est
fait aider chacun une personnalité
extrêmement importante et nous sommes
très en retard
depuis des années en ce qui concerne
l'éducation nationale je donne juste que
les ans nous sommes 23e sur le
classement de la réussite éducative dans
le monde 23e ya vraiment pas de quoi
faire cocorico
le deuxième exemple c'est que de plus en
plus de danse ayant c'est un métier
extrêmement complexe extrêmement
difficile de plus en plus d'enseignants
sont dans une forme stagiaires on avait
des instituts universitaires de
formation des maîtres
ils ont été fermés c'est une erreur une
erreur profonde une erreur aussi grande
que le numerus clausus pour les médecins
et maintenant tout le monde il n'y a pas
de médecin et donc au delà de nos choix
personnel voilà appliquées ou pas
appliquées sur sur la commune
c'est tellement important l'éducation on
n'a pas de temps deux mois il avait
préparé les différentes choses excusez
moi mais c'est tellement important que
ça devrait être portée coli
collectivement réveillon réveillon notre
éducation nationale elle en a bu et dont
on a besoin et nous allons intérêt pour
le débat concernant la ville de trappes
nous allons passer aux conclusions des
uns et des autres et vous donnez vos
temps de parole ali rabais vous êtes à
15 minutes 30 guy malandain à 16 minutes
30 et athmane natrue à 14 minutes 15
voilà même si le chrono a du mal à se
bloquer si vous le voyez s'afficher il a
quatorze minutes 20 voilà on m'a dit que
et vous étiez à 14 minutes 14 minutes 15
voilà ce qui fait que pour les
conclusions nous allons faire l'ordre
inverse par rapport à tout à l'heure
elle se sera donc ottomane mascouche qui
va qui va débuter
dima longtemps qu'il va décupler tout à
fait mais bien sûr excusez moi les
chronomètres mon peu perturbé guy
malandain vous allez débuter
vous n'aurez qu'une trentaine une
trentaine de secondes pour conclure
malheureusement eh bien je vais
simplement vous remercier d'une part et
d'autre part dire tous mes concitoyens
que avec mes ancrage politique avec mes
ancrage philosophique avec le
l'humanisme qui animent au quotidien que
je suis à leur disposition pour toutes
les années qui viennent pour constituer
continuer à conduire l'évolution de la
ville de trappes et l'équipe d'hommes et
de femmes de grande qualité qui
m'accompagneront pendant ce
ce délai est avec un espoir c'est que
quel que soit le résultat le choix
électoral trappe continue à s'épanouir
et la population à fraterniser et être
respecté les rabais c'est à vous pour
votre conclusion vous avez une minute
trente nous avait demandé une carte
blanche ou une carte blanche moi je
voulais relayé ici le combat du
collectif de défense du collège courbet
le collège courbet le département dirigé
par la droite a décidé de supprimer un
collège à trappes il est venu proposer à
la ville ce choix et je reprends là les
mots de la première adjointe au maire
jeanine mari elle a indiqué en conseil
municipal tout cela est évidemment fait
l'objet d'un compte rendu
nous avons donné un accord puisque de
toute façon à un moment donné il faut
effectivement qu'un collège soit
sacrifiée moi je considère qu'on ne joue
pas avec l'éducation des enfants et là
je prolonge le discours de guy malandain
sur le fait qu' il faut le mettre le
paquet sur l'éducation et la réussite
scolaires trap est une ville qui a
grandi considérablement on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui près de
trente deux 32 mille habitants vivent à
trappes
nous avons trois collèges à dimension
humaine entre 500 et 600 70 élèves
il n'est pas question de supprimer un
collège parce que si nous allions vers
la suppression d'un collège comme le
souhaite madame marie nous aurions
demain deux collèges à près de 1000
élèves
c'est irresponsable nous ne pouvons pas
avoir deux collèges de se rabaisser
merci moi mais je ne voudrais pas
interrompu et c'est peut-être du
département il est même si ça ne se fera
pas les n'était pas accusé par jésus
marie sont ce que j'ai répété là si
madame marion vous succès de monsieur
malandain puisque vous avez annoncé que
dans un an ou deux vous passeriez la
maintenance
si madame marie mise en scène non
monsieur je n'avais pas dit ça monsieur
vous les avez une place mesurant
monsieur bon ça républicaine
en tout cas vous avez répondu je
comptais si vous pouviez changer de
sujet et avancer il m'a longtemps vous a
répondu a donc fait sur mer si je suis
élu maire je me battrai pour que les
trois collège de trappes soient
préservés et que nos enfants grandissent
dans des collèges à taille humaine de se
ruiner c'est déjà prévu
c'est à vous vois que ma nation pour la
conclusion comme je disais vous avez un
peu plus de temps par rapport aux autres
puisque vous avez pris lui aussi du
retard 2 minutes 30 pour conclure tout
d'abord on n'arrive pas devant une
élection en proposant de faire le
contraire de ce qu'on a fait pendant six
ans pour laon pendant 20 ans pour
l'autre et donc je considère
qu'aujourd'hui la ville de trappes a
besoin d'un vrai changement et ce
changement il passe d'abord par le
rassemblement des trappistes c'est pour
ça qu'avec mustapha larbaoui nous avons
construit cette liste engagement trappe
citoyens qui est une équipe de
compétences avec des gens qui ont des
sensibilités politiques très différentes
moi je tiens à le redire ici un mandat
municipal ça n'est pas un mandat
partisans et amer c'est quelqu'un qui
doit chercher à rassembler parce que si
un maire se coupe d'une partie de sa
population qui n'a pas la même
sensibilité politique que lui s'il ne
sait pas que le quotidien d'une ville
les écoles les commerces la santé c'est
un rassemblement des habitants on aura
pas demain une gestion qui est une
gestion apaisée et je crois avoir
démontré ma capacité à rassembler avec
des élus de la majorité municipale
également qu'ils m'ont rejoint je crois
aussi que les trappistes mérite beaucoup
plus de résultats
alors j'entends les engagements des uns
et des autres encore une fois souvent en
contradiction avec ce qui a été fait
depuis
depuis six années maintenant mais la
réalité c'est que les trappistes peuvent
avoir mieux que ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui que la gestion municipale
actuelle que ils payent trop d'impôts
locaux pour le service public qui leur
est rendu que sur tout un tas de sujets
certaines villes arrivent à faire mieux
parce qu'ils ont des élus simplement
qu'ils obtiennent de meilleurs résultats
et moi je suis attaché ceux qui me
connaissent savent que je suis un homme
de rassemblement et un homme de résultat
concret et je crois que ça c'est quelque
chose d'important
vous aviez proposé de prendre un thème
qui n'a pas pu être abordés on a
beaucoup aimé vous parler de la sécurité
j'aurais aimé vous parler de l'emploi
sur laquelle là aussi il ya un constat
d'échec de la part de cette équipe
municipale avec quatre mille demandeurs
d'emploi trappe
mais je vais vous parler de nos anciens
je vous parlais de personnes âgées parce
que je crois qu'il ya un vrai sentiment
d'abandon aujourd'hui et bien que j'ai
gagné beaucoup d'expérience ces
dernières années je suis un jeune élu et
je crois que l'avis d'autres a pas
besoin de dynamique
mais je crois qu'elle a aussi besoin de
ces anciens à qui nous donnons pas
aujourd'hui le respect la tension et le
service qui l'aurait rendu sur
l'accompagnement sur l'animation mais
aussi quand on parle du fait qu'il y ait
30 % de médecins généralistes en moins
ou qu'il n'y ait quasiment plus de
commerces aujourd'hui à trappes plus une
seule charcuterie plus une seule
poissonnerie sur une ville de 32 mille
habitants mais je crois que les
premières personnes concernées qui font
les frais de ces manquements de la part
de la municipalité
ce sont nos seniors et j'aimerais avoir
une pensée pour eux parce qu'une ville
encore une fois ce n'est pas les jeunes
d'un côté seulement les seniors de
l'autre ce n'est pas un quartier compte
l'autre ça n'est pas une sensibilité
politique contre une autre c'est une
gestion efficace apaisé rassembler et
c'est pour cela qu'avec mustapha
larbaoui je suis fier aujourd'hui de
porter cette candidature qui je le crois
est une opportunité historique pour les
trappistes d'avoir une meilleure gestion
municipale que celle qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui
merci à tous les trois d'être venu
pouvoir débattre les temps forts qui
s'affiche une dernière fois
maintenant ce que 16 minutes 42 vous
avez un peu plus de retard a dit rabais
16 51 et guy malandain 17 minutes 16
d'ici au premier tour nous aurons le
temps bien sûr en allant vous voir les
uns et les autres sur le terrain des
guides égalisé tout ça merci encore à
vous de nous avoir suivis elle sur tv 78
radio sensations à bientôt pour un
nouveau débat du premier tour
[Musique]